[Music]
das das das das das is the only thing
everyone fears and the only thing that
gets me off hello my devilish darlings
I am Eleanor Olave your host is of
horror your rare and a radiant maiden of
may ha tonight's program is about the
death of meaning itself the story is
rather simple really
the he's become she and the she's become
he's and those in the middle are them
and them and then my dreadful dears the
Western world shall surely succumb to
renewable energy affordable health care
and video games for lesbians
but there's a one man who stands in the
way the villain of tonight's thriller a
meddling little cipher of a man a man
who prefers light to darkness reason to
madness order to chaos did you imagine
his name is ben shapiro and his
catchphrase facts don't care about your
feelings ah can our heroine put a stop
to this well I'm just the executioner
you my vial viewers must be the judge
[Music]
hi girls
it's me Miss points Matt musu POIs words
words words what do they even [ __ ]
mean well I don't know and I don't care
but we have to talk about it anyway
because if a boy named ben shapiro so
who is ben shapiro well he's a popular
conservative pundit the editor of The
Daily wire and the iturra behind such
criterion collection classics as ben
shapiro destroys yell snowflakes and
shapiro destroys every college snowflake
part 7 Dan Shapiro crushes anti-free
speech College snowflake and ben shapiro
destroy Caitlyn Jenner Ben's especially
notorious for his provocative
controversial politically incorrect
snowflakes smashing refusal to call
transgender people by their pronouns
willing to call Caitlyn Jenner Caitlyn
Jenner I'm not willing to call Caitlyn
Jenner is she surprising you might think
for a person so insistent on the value
of civil discussion and what speech
double right that's the tone of the day
and I'm a fan but Beth seems to abandon
civility in his discussions of trans
people preferring to fall back on his
edgy ER mantra facts don't care about
your feelings and you know on this one
point I actually agree with bad it's
true facts don't care about my feelings
I dislike this trend toward regarding as
a conclusive argument the proposition
this makes me feel invalidated because
sometimes things that make you feel bad
are true it makes me feel bad that I
used to be a sexy sexy boy with rippling
abs but too [ __ ] bad for me because
there I am and dela bleah exhibited on
YouTube for everyone to gawk out forever
I was a yum yum tho build me a time
machine doc we call this Auto and
ruefully a nurse what can I say I like
younger man I'm a cougar in Tigers
clothing so look I want to be treated
like an adult I don't want to be
indulged if I'm delusional they want to
be disillusioned I don't want people
lying to me just to protect whatever
deranged fantasy stories I need to tell
myself to make it through the night it's
so just dry down there they're just
ingrown hairs I'm sure plenty of healthy
people have blood in their urine I don't
want my gender to be tolerated in the
way that liberal Christians tolerate
other of course false and heathen
religions I am an evangelical
transsexual
I don't want toleration damn it I want
converts excuse me sir do a moment just
talk about my woman had sure go ahead
touch him
so look Shapiro Benny baby I invite you
to disenchant all of my fairy tales to
melt away every crystal of my snowflake
eree and henceforth dispense only there
was scalding tea all right big boy let's
have it I'm willing to call Caitlyn
Jenner Caitlyn Jenner I'm not willing to
call Caitlyn Jenner is she because you
can't change your sexting change right
Caitlyn Jenner is a man a biological man
and if he were born with high doses of
estrogen in his bloodstream he would
also not be a woman or that you were
determined by your chromosomes said the
argument is that what it means to be a
she is to have a normal female karyotype
that is exact sex chromosomes and if you
don't have that karyotype then you're
not a she and to call you she would be
tantamount to a lie but I was just
wondering what you see the detriment of
society like why we can't like let a
transgender like woman be called she or
something because it is a lie so since
you think that calling a trans woman she
is a lie and you think that what it
means to be a she is to have a normal
female karyotype then you must think
that when we call trans woman she we are
saying that she has a normal female
karyotype but hold on I am a transgender
woman and I have never claims to have a
normal female karyotype yet my friends
lovers and most strangers call me she
her Miss ma'am girlfriend ladies good
girl
just like that don't stop don't stop are
all of us deluded about my biology now
it is not I who misunderstands biology
Ben Shapiro
it is you who misunderstands language
you have deceptively framed the debate
as a debate about biology which it is
not we all agree on the biology the
actual subject of the debate is the
proper use of words such as he/she man
and woman but how do we decide on the
correct way to use a word well there are
two kinds of arguments we could make
descriptive or prescriptive if we take
the descriptive approach then what we
must do is act like anthropologists and
study the way a word for instance she is
used by a linguistic community and
whatever the social convention is is
what's correct but if we take the
prescriptive approach that we must make
an argument about the way the word is
she should be used
meaning we either defer to an authority
such as the dictionary
well my ruler on your wrists you naughty
boy or we must have some goal that we
want to accomplish by approving some
uses of the word and prohibiting others
now if we take the descriptive approach
you lose ben shapiro because most people
call me she and that's all there is to
it what's more your usage of Oishi and
aji is ungrammatical you don't put an
article before pronoun that's not how
pronouns work you silly dumbed down also
human sex chromosomes were discovered in
1905 while the English pronouns he and
she originated in the proto-germanic
language spoken during the pre-roman
Iron Age of Northern Europe beginning
around 500 BCE
therefore by insisting that the singular
third-person pronouns of the English
language refers specifically to
karyotype it is you and not I who is
breaking from linguistic tradition ben
shapiro however as a trans woman it's
not generally in my interest to defer to
traditions so let's try out a
prescriptive approach without simply
appealing to the way a word is already
used how do we decide how a word should
be
language is by nature ambiguous and the
way we attempt to disambiguate it is
often motivated by political goals then
shapiro thinks we should not call
transwomen she because his political
goal is to reinforce rigid conservative
gender roles whereas I think we should
call trans women she because my
political goal is to live in a society
where I can achieve the same level of
sadness and dysfunction as everyone else
is analogous to the debate about
same-sex marriage from a decade ago
opponents argue the dictionary and legal
definition of marriage was union between
a man and a woman and the definition
shouldn't be changed because it's the
definition and how am I supposed to
explain to my child and on the other
hand gay people argue that the
definition should be changed because
they want it to achieve the same level
of sadness and dysfunction as everyone
else and they succeeded because as it
turns out you can in fact change the
definitions of words
the dictionary is simply a usage guide
it's not the Bible and for that matter
you can change the Bible I mean have you
read the contemporary English version
the prose is atrocious appalling I won't
stand for this
but unlike the debate about gay marriage
the question of our trans womanhood is
more than just a political and legal
dispute it seems to me that whatever
church state and merriam-webster decide
trans women already are and will
continue to be women and to see why I
want to elaborate on an argument posed
to ben shapiro by my sometime rival
blair white yes even though she's one of
the youtubers boost is bad the debate
begins with ben shapiro asserting his
usual position that pronouns are used to
designate so-called biological men and
biological women blair responds by
observing that ben's a way of using
pronouns is in her case completely
impractical well if you and i were to go
to a business dinner or any kind in ER
and you were meeting me at a restaurant
and i was there first and I was in an
orange shirt and you had to tell you
know the host I'm here to meet my friend
Blair and they said okay and you had to
describe me to take me to the table you
wouldn't say the man in the orange shirt
you would say Blair and you would say
her
over there Ben then responds saying I
think there's some truth to that meaning
that I think that there is a utility to
the use of pronouns but that's not quite
the same as suggesting that a
transgender woman is a she in the
objective sense and Blair responds to
that with what I think is a very good
analogy for instance if someone were to
adopt children there's no biological
basis for calling them that kids parent
right because they're not like they're
just literally not there's no link at
all biologically but there is a social
reason to do it and there's a legal
reason to do it let's expand on that
analogy suppose you're an adoptive
parent and you're arguing with someone
who says your adopted child isn't really
your child and you aren't really a
parent as evidence they point to the
dictionary definition of parent one that
begets or brings forth offspring you did
not B get a ring fourth offspring they
argue therefore you are not a parent
facts don't care about your feelings no
matter how much you love and care for
this child you'll never be anything but
a glorified kidnapper I think it's clear
that the person who makes this argument
is being uncivil yes being provocative
controversial politically incorrect but
they're not just impolite they're also
wrong because an adoptive parent is
socially and functionally just as real a
parent as a biological parent and to say
otherwise is not just rude it's false so
what do you have to say to that Ben
Shapiro I wouldn't say that we actually
do have different descriptions for
adoptive parents than biological parents
right you'll say in shorthand that their
parents because they're all different
types of parents but we do say adoptive
parents right adoptive parents an
entirely valid type of parent to call
them parents is not a lie and then the
question becomes okay exactly is the
context that you were suggesting matters
in what context are we talking about the
parents are we talking about a PTA
meeting okay this person is the legal
guardian and therefore the parent
because parenting has two aspects right
there's the biological parentage and
then there is the actual role of
parenting so yes there are some contexts
where we do need to distinguish between
biological and adoptive parents for
instance if a doctor is assessing a
child's risk of some hereditary disease
they need to know if the parents are
adoptive or biological but at the PTA
meeting and in most other contacts
it doesn't matter in the slightest in
the in the dinner conversation the same
thing sort of holds true meaning there's
the biological role of woman which
you're not and then there is the you
look like a woman which is I'm gonna
describe the you as a woman to the
waiter when he comes to the recomme to
the table just one Bend seems on the
cusp of having a breakthrough he and
Blair pause their argument to
congratulate themselves and how civil
their discussion is from what I've seen
a lot of your interactions with trans
people I always end up kind of ugly you
know what I mean there was the I think I
think the person's name was Zoe turn
there was the threat of physical
violence your genetics you cut that out
now or you'll go home in an ambulance
yeah I mean what's hilarious about this
Blair is literally the exact same thing
that I'm saying to you right now is
exactly what I said to Zoe to her on the
air but that's not exactly true is it
Ben
Zoe threatened you after you called her
sir and he didn't call Blair sir did you
why did you call Zoe sir
what kind of reaction were you hoping to
elicit ODIs ting guaa stroy er of
snowflakes I suppose you were just
sticking to the facts I suppose sir is a
strictly biological term Queen Guinevere
said in days of old I Knight thee
Lancelot thou the dart carrier typically
male and you're exactly right when
people start yelling at each other or
tweeting out fu that's not a great way
to change my mind it turns out that's
not particularly convincing so what is a
great way to change your mind Ben
Shapiro
did Blair budge you an inch with her
rationality her even temper her civility
her aesthetic it doesn't seem like she
did at the end of this to be you
regurgitate your original position
undigested you know I'm the editor of a
pretty major site and my basic rule is
that when we were discussing people are
trans we immediately say in the first
paragraph trans woman and then refers
them by their biological pronoun because
biology is the nature of the pronoun
biology is the nature of the pronouns
didn't Blair just demonstrate to you
that in most contexts that's not true
for her remember the analogy of adoptive
parents there were some contexts where
it makes sense to distinguish between
adoptive parents and biological parents
likewise there are some scientific and
medical contexts where it makes sense to
distinguish between transgender and
cisgender or as you say biological women
for instance when discussing who needs
access to certain reproductive health
care you think should be illegal but
does this apply to pronouns that is are
pronouns technical biological terms to
noting karyotypes
or are they part of the everyday
language we use to describe each other
socially the answer is obvious there are
no geneticists studying pronouns in fact
there's not a single biology textbook
with a chapter on the difference between
a he and a she there is no such thing as
biological pronouns this is a phrase
invented in the last decade to describe
the misgendering of trans people so as a
trans woman i'm reintegrating myself
into society as a woman she pronouns are
therefore most appropriate for me
regardless of my Anatomy which is none
of your business ben shapiro fascinating
though it is and just as is encouraged
to tell an adoptive mother that her son
is not her child to call me he is not
just rude or insensitive it is in effect
false but it is also rude and
insensitive so even if you don't agree
with me you could still not what's the
harm right I teach my almost 4 year old
girl that she can become a boy then I
think that is not only lying to her I
think it's confusing her and I think
it's damaging to her psyche oh yes the
classic argument how do I explain to my
child to kill your shitty childhood role
I care that's simply not my problem I
regret every night I spent with you Ben
Shapiro I met a new relationship now
with the lesbian you and I are through
I'm getting an abortion and you can't
stop me
it's disgusting what they allow on TV
these days I won't allow my children to
watch movies unless there's at least a
bloodbath or maybe an orgy but hey I
don't choose this schlock I just
presented the second program of
tonight's science fiction double feature
is about a cult of chaos hell-bent on
destroying Western civilization I sure
hope there's more sex and violence this
time it's points again same queen new
look try to keep up in my previous video
nasty tea babe likes it rough I made an
argument about why it's correct to go
trans women she but I'd be bullshitting
you if I only discussed fully-integrated
binary trans people everyone basically
calls them by their pronouns already
dingbats like ben shapiro have to exert
conscious effort to continue the charade
of misgendering though the transgender
woman from orange is the new black i
never watch that i've never watched that
show either but she's not a comfort Time
magazine oh or he's on the cover of Time
magazine I limited my argument to trans
women who look the way society expects a
woman to look because it says people
have an easier time making sense of that
but the reality is that in a lot of
cases it's a little more complicated now
as far as early transition trans people
go I am fairly integrated Society
basically gets that I'm a woman without
me having to explain my gender strangers
usually default to she/her miss ma'am
hey haven't I seen your videos on t girl
love.com but the truth is I don't pass
perfectly I got cold sir last week by
the cashier in H&M not that I usually
deign to shop at H&M but needless to say
it was a desperate emergency and by
emergency I mean I met a cute busboy at
PF Changs and what happened next stays
between me and the Lord but suffice to
say that my blouse was irrevocably
drenched in okay i embellished the story
a little
so between being 6 foot 1 the horrific
transsexuals squawking I try to pass off
as my voice and my tragic inability to
conduct myself in a manner befitting a
lady of good breeding your girl remains
just
my desperate painstaking efforts
somewhat claw Keable you look great hon
and that debate between Ben and Blair
Blair says that pronoun usage boils down
to what you look like but it really does
kind of boil down to what you look like
and it's true that most strangers will
choose a pronoun for you largely based
on your appearance
so appearance definitely matters but in
my opinion passing in the sense of
looking like a sis woman is really the
most important thing what matters more
to me is the kind of vibe you give them
the way you speak the gestures the
conversation will dynamic that kind of
stuff to me is what makes a person
viscerally seem like a man or a woman so
my goal isn't necessarily to serve
unlockable fish so much as to embody a
certain kind of diaphanous archetypal
femininity in layman's terms girl dick
energy also I am gonna have a lot of
plastic surgery thank God last month I
released a video called sexy furry
pounded by skinny T babe and a lot of
trans people got mad at me because they
thought I was saying that performing
your gender is the only thing that
matters and that how you identify counts
for nothing but that's not what I think
I do prefer to argue that trans women
are women because we live the lives of
women because I think that's a much more
compelling argument than I'm a woman
because I psychologically identify as a
woman which and my experience doesn't
really persuade anyone it's just too
easy to poke holes in them but identity
definitely does matter especially when
it comes to pronouns it'll explain why
now first I should acknowledge that a
lot of sis people are very sensitive
about anyone telling them what pronouns
to use so I'm gonna try to be respectful
of your feelings and what a difficult
impersonal issue this must be for you
after all we live in a repressive
political era despite the best efforts
of hero professor Jordan B Peterson but
alas he was too late now we hope you'll
see a 16 which compels speech and sense
people to jail for oh it's been more
than a year since bill C 16 passed let's
check in on how many people have gone to
jail for pronoun misuse
[Music]
guess that was a false alarm ah damn it
look I'm not gonna tell you what
pronouns you have to use I'm just gonna
tell you how I use pronouns am i
reasoning behind it and you are welcome
to use your free speech to choose how
much of an obstinate Hobgoblin you want
to be okay so back to identity if I were
a cashier at the Emporium of ethereal
trinkets and a customer were to walk in
looking like this I might ordinarily
default to female pronouns but that
would be wrong since I happen to know
this person is not only a man he is the
man YouTube's most regal makeup artist
his lordship John McClane and he uses
he/him pronouns likewise if I were
approached by this person I had fall in
love and then default to female pronouns
and this time I'd be correct but not
because she's assist woman or a trans
woman but because she's gender fluid
drag queen Courtney out who is a [ __ ]
audacity to be a more beautiful woman
than I am and who so far as I know uses
male pronouns and blend mode and female
pronouns and girl mode has two most
Queens a lot of the complexities of
gender language identity and expression
get played out in the world of drag some
queens like RuPaul just identify assist
man who live as men and perform as women
others like Courtney Sasha velour jinkx
monsoon shake cool eh and violet chachki
identify as non-binary others still are
bio queens sis women who perform as drag
queens like Lucy Garland or creme fatale
and then there are trans women who are
also dry Queens like peppermint imp
Queen or for that matter me I mean look
at me do you think I dress like this
when I go to 7-eleven at 2:00 a.m.
because I do look what I have become a
bisexual transexual drag queen look I
didn't intend to become this much of a
snowflake I just through pure
coincidence happen to be the most
interesting and unique person who ever
lived I am so sorry I can't how bad so
let's recap there are gender
non-conforming men who present a very
fun but use male pronouns your
assessment who use female pronouns
whenever they present female there were
gender-fluid people who use different
pronouns depending on their current
presentation there are free transition
trans people who identify as a gender
other than the one they present and live
as and prefer other pronouns so you
really can't
rely on the way a person looks because
there's a lot of situations where the
way they look doesn't tell you the whole
story so as you can see identity
definitely is important but it's also
not the only thing that matters a
psychological identity were the only
thing that mattered and there would be
no need for a trans person to come out
or do anything to transition including
requesting different pronouns because
pronouns belong to the social world of
language not to individual psychology
this is an idea I tried to explore in my
sexy furry video you can identify
however you like but gender is also
social structural in interpersonal so if
for example you're a trans woman still
living as a man then you are fully trans
your identity is fully valid but until
you begin living as a woman your
womanhood remains kind of hypothetical
and when I say living as a woman I don't
mean passing there's too much emphasis
on physical appearance and not enough on
social relationships you know you don't
become a woman the first time you put on
a dress you become a woman the first
time an older female relative turns to
at a restaurant and says maybe you
should order the salad sweetie my point
is not to invalidate anyone's identity
as far as I'm concerned if a trans
person hasn't transitioned yet they are
fully trans I'm just trying to be
realistic about the fact that a lot of
people's gendered experience isn't
entirely a product of how they identify
but it this way I will always use female
pronouns for a trans woman but my
thought process behind it isn't always
the same many trans women just seem like
women to me and literally the same way
that sis women seem like women and I use
female pronouns for them effortlessly
just as I was trained to do from birth
this I think is the goal for most binary
trans people we want not necessarily to
pass perfectly but at least to seem like
our genders to the people around us as
Laura Jane grace put it you want them to
see you like they see every other girl I
want people calling me she not out of
politeness or respect for my identity as
a trans a la man but just because I seem
like a woman to them because the reality
is not all trans women seem like a woman
to me in that visceral way and I live
with this constant crushing anxiety
though I don't seem like a woman to
other people I'm terrified of looking
like a third-rate drag queen and I cope
with that fear
by looking like a second-rate drag queen
but look even if a person is giving my
eyes and ears a 0% woman if she tells me
you the trans woman I'm gonna use female
pronouns no matter what she looks not
just to be polite but also because I
want to recognize the reality of her
psychological experience and especially
because I want to help her resocialize
and reintegrate into the world as her
true gender and of course sis people you
legally have the freedom to refuse to do
that but if he refuse you are being a
[ __ ] Gibbon and I would prefer that you
not be a [ __ ] Gibbon now we need to
address the gender queer elephant in the
room
an increasing number of people identify
not as male or female but as non-binary
an umbrella term encompassing a bunch of
more specific labels such as gender
queer gender fluid a gender grey gender
and so on
many of these people use a non-binary
pronoun in English usually they now if
your verse impulse is to argue that
singular dazon grammatical nonsense
consider that having gendered singular
third-person pronouns at all is a
particular feature of the English
language as by no means shared by all
other languages including Turkish Korean
Finnish which don't have them at all
language is just a bunch of [ __ ]
sounds coming out of your mouth the
human's makeup to suit our purposes if
your new teasing singular day it is a
little confusing at first but with some
practice it gets pretty easy they poured
milk on me I poured milk on them they
didn't themself in their milk and it was
good thus saith the Lord
so the blight thing to do here is easy
if someone asks you to call them Fae you
call them they but if you're like me you
don't want to just do a thing because
you'd automatically believe it's the
woke thing to do you want to understand
why you're doing it I don't just want to
tolerate non-binary people I want to be
a convert
I want to believe about them well they
believe about themselves so long as
those beliefs are reasonable so what do
all these words mean what are these
people talking about remember earlier we
distinguish gender expression from
gender identity John McClane is feminine
in expression but a man
identity whereas I am a woman in
identity in an expression I am a mess
let us meditate upon the lesbian
cultures great contributions to humanity
are science spirituality sexuality
metaphysics the foot scale the foot
scale is a diagram that looks like this
and quantifies from 1 to 10 over - to
stone butch the gender expression of a
given domain such as moulin looks or
Steven universe characters it can also
be used more abstractly for weapons fish
Pokemon or wind instruments maybe wood
non-binary people are trying to do with
words like genderqueer
a gender grey gender and so on is to
give to identity the same kind of
specificity the foot scale gives to
expression but my input on this isn't
really worth that much because I'm not
non-binary and it tell you the truth I
kind of feel for sis people here because
all of us talk about gender identity a
lot of the time I don't really get it
either I look inside myself and ask do I
feel like a man or a woman and after all
these years the answer is still that I
feel like [ __ ] and that's how I
experienced gender I live I exist as a
woman which is the only way I can
achieve the same level of sadness and
dysfunction as everyone else
and I identify as trash I guess there
are certain moments that make me feel
like a natural woman no listening to
Aretha Franklin the pain and ecstasy of
penetration waiting in a long ass line
for the restroom a big strong arm around
my waist being asked if I have any
tampons having tampons in case someone
asks a dude explaining philosophy 101 to
me and me going oh really wow but you
know these experiences mean different
things at different people so all I can
really tell you is that I prefer to
express myself with diaphanous feminine
gestures without taking female hormones
and having feminizing medical procedures
makes me feel more at home in my body
and that I like it when other people
treat me as a woman socially spiritually
sexually so that's the jargon free
explanation of my gender as I see it am
I really truly a woman ontologically
neurologically metaphysically well
honestly I don't even know what that
would mean but I do know that the life I
live as a woman is the only life I
have and that I think is legitimate
enough so I know it living as a woman
means to me but what does it mean to
live a non-binary life well just like
what it means to be a man or a woman
that's something that's gonna vary
between individuals and cultures some
cultures have ancient third gender
traditions such as the Hedra of South
Asia a legally recognized gender in
India Pakistan Nepal and Bangladesh for
the various two-spirit traditions of
indigenous North American tribes
non-indigenous American culture doesn't
have a third gender tradition but we do
have individual non-binary people some
of whom are making content that has
taught me a lot about non-binary
experience non-binary bodies and
non-binary life we have a lot in common
binary and non-binary trans people even
as a binary trans person I used to live
as one gender and now I live as another
gender that in itself is a pretty
serious challenge to the stability of
the binary but many of the people who
call themselves non-binary seem to be
fighting for something more radical than
what I'm fighting for at least in my
personal life I'm just trying to
assimilate into a pre-existing female
gender role as you can see by the normal
way I'm dressed the traditional garb of
my culture or near near me or on ER me
or know where as non-binary people are
trying to cast off these roles entirely
they're effectively trying to create the
society that includes them and sometimes
that puts me at cross-purposes with some
non-binary people who for example
promote the practice of always asking
for someone's pronouns whereas I love it
when people assume my gender provided
the assume it correctly otherwise I will
throw you an imaginary Canadian pronoun
jail but what we all agree on is that
many trans non-binary and gender
non-conforming people find it easier to
navigate the world using pronouns other
than the ones that Ben Shapiro wants you
to use so if you want me to call you a
I'm gonna call you that and though I
cannot and will not force you viewer to
do or say anything I do hope you use
your freewill to freely choose to use
your freedom of speech to choose to do
the same freely
well at least there was a hideous
monster this time I'm talking about a
female lead now the fun really begins
the show's over I'm gonna go take my
tits out at a funeral parlor
so goodbye my Satanic subscribers until
next week go to hell
[Music]
[Applause]